today is a deadline for contractors to
submit proposals for the first part of
president Trump's Mexico border wall
custom and Border Protection says it
must be 18 to 30 feet high and extend at
least six feet underground to block
tunnels it should be difficult to climb
or breach and be aesthetically pleasing
on the US side the US side okay CBS News
has learned that first 48 miles will go
up in San Diego and along the Rio Grande
at a cost of nearly a billion dollars
David Bennett was in Brownsville Texas
where this wall could split a community
right into David good morning Gail good
morning from the border this golf course
has in the past been a runway for people
coming here illegally from the other
side that's Mexico they would swim
across the Rio Grande run up onto the
golf course and watch this they would
run into this cave right here hiding
themselves or their drugs but the golf
courses owner is started to cut down the
cane and with it the number of people
coming here illegally struck
dramatically now President Trump's new
wall may help
however it would divide 700 Americans
who live right here in this community
with more than 300 acres the Riverbend
Resort is one of the few areas left in
Brownsville Texas without a border fence
many of the retirees who live here want
to keep it that way it's not needed
Border Patrol's in here all the time
they launch their boats at our boat ramp
and are here within 30 seconds Greg hi
and his wife Lauren voted for President
Trump they think the money for the wall
would be better spent on resources for
border agents better cameras maybe some
more drones a treaty with Mexico
prohibits anything that could have
struck or deflect the Rio Grande so when
the Bush administration built its border
fence it wanted to do it right in the
middle of River Bend if the Trump
administration follows suit the wall
goes up essentially what it does is
splits the resort community in half and
you've got 200 people living on this
side and 400 of their friends on what
becomes the Mexican side of the wall
that would mean 70% of the resort
including 15 holes on the golf course
would be
kind of a no-man's land between the
fence and the actual border but it's not
just a golf course it's a family
business
Jeremy Barnard is another Trump
supporter he's also River Ben's general
manager John Garrett owns JP
construction the Fort Worth company with
50 employees he's submitting his border
wall proposal today it's gonna create a
lot of jobs for unemployed construction
workers veterans individuals the Trump
administration is seeking bids for
prototypes with a see-through component
and made with concrete or other
materials they never talked about all
the people that died trying to make it
across to the United States and leave it
so you know I think it'll save a lot of
lives also the federal government
controls less than a third of the nearly
2,000 mile long southern border the rest
belongs to the state's Native American
tribes or like River Bend is privately
owned the government could come in offer
you an amount if you don't like it they
could seize it through eminent domain
you know that I do yeah and I get to Sen
see you're ready to fight if that
happens then we have already retained a
lawyer and we're ready to make sure that
we were compensated fairly for it Jeremy
says that the government pays the price
tag would be in the millions and he
doubts they would want to pay that now
Nora I know some people may be sitting
at home sarcastically thinking these
poor rich golfers might be losing their
course but please know that the people
who live here in South Texas are
middle-class folks retirees many of them
who have moved up from the north to
retire here and every one of them we
spoke to believes this would have a
negative effect on them economically
David thank you they're in the weeds on
this story but it's a really good
example of it was nice to have Trump
voter saying that they opposed the wall
in it because it shows how complicated
this story really is and I wonder how
many other examples there are along the
wall where it's disrupting where it's
doing more harm than good
right David pointed out in his story and
also what came up during the health care
debate it's very interesting thank you
David thank you